listen man big fan and I love Luther it
is awesome to talk to you for the Luther
movie thanks man very very proud of this
movie thanks for having me I definitely
want to start with a probably the most
important question up front uh you made
beasts of no nation and then you made
Beast uh when can we expect the third
film in the Idris Elba Beast Trilogy
well it's Beast is a great word all
right and uh it could uh definitely you
know I I heard a I heard a rumor that
you know graphic designers or brand
makers love five letter words and you
know it just looks aesthetically great
so Luther
the broken Beast or something I don't
know that could be the next installment
I'm all in on that
um being serious when you made Luther uh
you were given about five dollars and a
roll of duct tape to make the episodes
so what was it like making the movie
where you actually had a budget and
craft service it felt a little bit you
know lavish if I'm honest uh you know we
took sequences
that were very expensive where we could
have made a sixth season out of to your
point but um actually I think that
Luther really has sort of earned its
stripes now you know we've done the TV
thing and I think we did that well
considering the duct tape and uh and the
uh crafty Services budget however now we
have this really slightly larger scale
which I think it deserves and I think if
we move this
film franchise forward it would be great
to see what we can do in different
Landscapes wouldn't it be interesting to
see Luther in you know Chile or Luther
in La wouldn't it be great listen sir
I'm all in if you make them I will push
play immediately
um being serious this film does have a
like a big sequence in Piccadilly Circus
you have a big action set piece in the
prison can you sort of talk about
filming those sequences because it is a
lot different than the series yeah I
think you know Piccadilly Circus is
definitely like uh wait what they said
yes I mean you know it's really
difficult to get any sort of filming
where you can shut down Piccadilly
Circus but it turns out the person that
signs off the uh filming rights of those
areas was a Luther fan so thanks very
much for doing that
um but definitely we had you know sort
of our toys in our favorite toys in our
in our Sam and sandbox and being able to
do that the prison sequence again we
don't usually do fight sequences in
Luther but we wanted to do one that was
memorable and one that felt within the
sort of brand language if you like you
know sort of messy and not really fight
sequency but just you know visual I
definitely have to ask you like I said
as a fan um have you guys actually
talked about being serious like what you
would do if you get to make another
movie yeah we've definitely explored
that we've figured out that we want to
keep the stakes High we want to keep the
brand language to Luther the same we
don't suddenly want to turn into this
big you know Mission Impossible style
thing where everything's a bit like Whoa
We want to keep it grounded but at the
same time we want to have the scale that
we've uh that we've established with the
first movie uh sir I have to rap I'm
just gonna say I really hope a lot of
people watch because I I want you making
another
thanks brother thanks appreciate you
have a great day thank you